[Music]
Lara Croft at the beginning of this game
is someone who is searching for answers
and in almost a level of being obsessed
with finding these answers you're seeing
a level of determination and almost
stubbornness in a way to follow leads
that could put her life on the line so
it's this extra determination this
willingness to go further to do things
that other humans maybe wouldn't be
willing to do that makes her especially
unique in this game we had a fantastic
opportunity for the reboot to redesign
Lara from the ground up and in a lot of
ways that's very daunting also very
exciting for our team kam was a big part
of that he talks very passionately about
what it takes to construct Lara Croft
but a lot of that comes down to what
know is looking for and what I'm looking
for as far as who she is and and why one
of the exciting things about bringing
Lara to life this time is we're able to
leverage new technology to do that but
before I get into that it's important to
start with Lara's characterization what
was important for us in the reboot and
even more so going forward even as we
take lara farther down her journey as a
as a character was to maintain that
sense of humanity that sense of
relatability that this isn't a superhero
this is someone like URI whose thrust
into these extraordinary situations and
rises to the occasion so it's not that
she doesn't feel fear it's that she is
able to muster courage to overcome that
fear she's always been academic and
smart and strong in her own way but she
has this new confidence and this drive
to try to discover these truths it's
unlocked and kindled a fire inside of
her wanting to find out what these these
ancient secrets could actually mean and
and her father's passion something that
she didn't understand before she's
starting to grapple with and understand
this is not only something that she's
interested in but as part of a family
legacy and in ways you could say it's
reckless but it's really a story about
her becoming who she's meant to be being
a Tomb Raider is something that not
anyone can do you know Lara is uniquely
qualified to be who she's meant to be
which is the Tomb Raider we really
wanted in this game to put Lara into
this world and make her look as if she
really existed in that environment so as
she goes through her adventure she'll
get dirty she'll get bloody if she gets
attacked she'll also get snow on her
snow accumulate on her shoulders if
she's in a snowy environment we're
really trying to push that physicality
in order to really ground Lara in this
environment and make her look like she's
a part of this world as you're running
through the world you see that
nervousness on her face when you're in a
scary tomb or she's seen a trap and she
knows there may be a trap around any
corner that we place Lara in that moment
or whether she's affected by if she's
scrambling around in the dirt she's
gonna get dirty and if she's going
through water she's gonna get wet and if
she's dammit she's gonna get bloody and
all of these facets of both capturing
her emotions but really translating
those in a way where even as you're
playing the game she feels alive in that
same way when Brandon Fernandez our
animation director imagines Lara Croft
in this world he sees her as an active
partner in whatever is happening so if
she's in a tight claustrophobic space
she will touch the walls and be aware of
her her surroundings if if she takes a
particularly hard fall you'll see her
clutch her side or her head
to acknowledge the damage if if you see
lhara you know in a particularly damaged
state she'll start to be woozy and
stammered around in the world there's a
scene in the last game where she got hit
in the face by Vlad with a gun this is
in that scene where she first kill scene
where it was transformational for her so
I wanted to take some of that game and
some of that history and put it into
this game for that sense of continuity
so if you look really carefully at her
model you'll see that a little left over
scar from that from that scene we wanted
her to react to the environment not only
in the sense that when she's cold and
she'll she'll rub herself or when she
walks by a fire she'll warm her hands so
she's actually a part of this world
she's actually exists in there and it
makes people believe that this is a real
person
one of the most challenging things about
this version of Lara we started using
facial blend shapes in this game which
we never had in the last game but by
incorporating this technology we are
actually able to capture a lot of the
nuances in the actors performance Lara
has over a hundred facial blend shapes
that she uses in order to to show her
emotions in order to talk and blink and
what it allows us to do is really
capture that the every nuance and
Camila's performance and show it in game
and it's it's quite stunning when you
look at it but the hard part really is
just a balance all of that all of the
shapes so they look correct and as she
stays on character that's always been a
really big challenge to make her to look
like a believable character and that
she's she has human emotions and if we
can convey that in the blend shapes I
think that was that was one of the
biggest challenges we've taken the hair
technology from the last game and we
built on that and made a very robust
system a much more powerful system than
we had in the last game her hair
actually now has up to 30,000 strands we
put a lot of work into the physics as
well so when the wind blows it the
ponytail will blow very naturally when
she turns a head the ponytail will roll
off her shoulders and that hair is so
important to to us to get right because
it's such an iconic part of her
character we put a lot of work into
making it look just perfect in some way
she represents adventure that she
embodies everything that's awesome and
exciting about action-adventure games so
whether it's solving puzzles or
platforming or combat or exploration or
great rewards and great storytelling
that all
this is really embodied by Lara Croft
and it's it's a pleasure to be able to
take something that's so unique and
singular but apply it to an experience
that's so universal and exciting